has been a lot of speculation about what
the new england patriots are going to do
could they trade up if one of these guys
like trey lance slips past the top 10
bill belichick dropping some bread
crumbs last week to suggest maybe they
would
we can't overlook the fact that sims and
i discussed today that belichick loves
cam newton and one of the reasons he
loves cam newton at a time when
topic a
throughout the nfl
guys choosing to stay away from
voluntary offseason workouts who's there
with bells on day one
cam newton ready to do what he didn't
have the chance to do last year didn't
join the patriots until late june
wasn't available to do anything until
training camp was learning on the fly
now he knows the offense he's learning
it better he's in the building he's
around he's soaking it in
that's all the patriots can really ask
for and i think that's one of the
reasons why
they maybe shouldn't be desperate to
find a quarterback they can develop
because
these guys only a decade into his career
he's got
years left you don't have to go draft a
guy that's going to sit
behind cam newton maybe for two three
four years like a jordan loving green
bay so i think this cam newton factor
he's there he's getting ready and i
think he's going to be pretty good this
year i think that makes it less likely
the patriots go all in on a quarterback
in round one and try to maybe move up to
get one of the top five five guys miles
okay two things i mean hey i don't
necessarily know that i see the features
moving all the way up you know just that
doesn't
i was i mean i'm gonna say it doesn't
seem to be in their mo but neither did
you know signing all those free agents
but also i just
i don't know about cam newton man i just
i think that he was an effective
quarterback at some points in the season
last year and i think kovid seemed to
affect him and you know you look at the
numbers pre and post covid there were
some things there that are kind of
eye-opening but i also just i don't know
you look at some of those games that he
had and i didn't watch every single
patriots game last year but i mean on
that game that he played against the los
angeles rams on thursday night football
man my goodness i know that the rams
defense was the best in the league last
year but boy he just cam newton did not
look like he could be an effective
quarterback for a 17-game season and by
that i mean somebody that you can rely
on to also make the throws as well as
the runs that he can obviously make and
so
i don't know they need to be desperate
to find a quarterback but at the same
time i'm just not sure
if cam newton is going to be the guy
who's going to be able to lead you to
the promised land from the standpoint
that your quarterback kind of has to
throw us the ball sometimes right i mean
this is almost the same thing we were
just talking about with the ravens lamar
jackson i'm just i'm not convinced that
camden can do that but i think when
we're talking about guys coming in
and making sure that they're in front of
coaches to win a roster spot this is
exactly what we mean this is why all
this nfl pa stuff and all these
statements you know
whatever they're gonna say what they're
going to say but guys are still going to
show up because guys want a job and when
it comes down to it they're going to be
selfish in that regard if you can even
call it that and show up to these
voluntary workouts so they get a leg up
cam newton doesn't mean doesn't need me
to take up his cause he's a former nfl
mvp there were problems last year and i
really do think it was a covet 19
situation and think about this they went
to la for two games with only
three days between them they played on a
sunday they played on a thursday on
sunday they looked great against the
chargers it was that thursday night game
against the rams that went off the rails
you know and and newton
he denied having brain fog in the
aftermath of having cove but something
wasn't right because pre-covert
not a huge sample size but they beat the
crap out of the raiders and i think i
think they could have given the chiefs
everything they could handle they did
they did give the chiefs everything they
could handle without cam newton so
at a time when we've heard so much about
guys who aren't going to be there or who
say they aren't going to be there
there's been a lot of huff and puff over
the course of the last week we'll see
how many houses get blown down but when
cam newton is there day one and when you
consider all the guys they've added at
the skill position specifically tight
end of receiver to help him
i think we're going to see a different
cam newton this year and i think if bill
belichick believes that
that makes him more likely to say
thank you that there's going to be five
quarterbacks taken before i pick at
number 15 instead of i have to go get
one of them
so the second time you've referenced the
three little pigs i feel like in the
last two or three weeks mike you're just
reading nursery rhymes what's going on
with you man
i i like saying huff and puff
in that context and only that context
that's fun no but i mean i agree with
you at the at a certain point right like
it just it feels like the patriots could
certainly wait until they get on the
clock at 15 see what's available to them
maybe if a quarterback does slip if it's
a guy that they really feel like they
believe in yeah you pick him there or
you know maybe you just trade back and
you do the thing that i feel like you
would think the patriots would do which
is gain a little bit more picks gain
some more flexibility there and just
pick a guy who fits exactly what you
want to do and continue to try to build
this offense around cam newton i
understand
why someone would want to build their
offense around somebody who was a past
mvp and it really wasn't that long ago
that cam newton was still playing at a
high level but i think over the last
couple years with all the different
injuries that he's had especially that
injury to his shoulder
it's just
i just i hate to say that cam newton has
something to prove because he wasn't in
vp right like they they went to the
super bowl they were 15 and one he
doesn't necessarily have something to
prove but he also does because he still
has to prove that he can stay healthy
and be an effective passer for a 17 game
season so i don't i don't like using
that term but it's the only term that's
coming to my brain right now for him
well and to the extent we talk about
guys finding motivation and being
doubted there aren't many quarterbacks
being doubted more currently than cam
newton in the nfl so if that's where
he's looking for motivation if that's
how he's wired he doesn't have to make
it up he doesn't have to pretend that
somebody said something bad about him
the night before he goes out and has a
big game yeah i mean it's look everyone
is doubting not everyone but a lot of
people are just like is this really the
guy
in 2015 no how close is he to being that
guy and how close can he ever come to
being that guy again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports